Elon Musk is on the road to autonomy at
least he says he is
he had an announcement last night where
he said he plans to equip all new Tesla
cars with the hardware needed for full
self-driving capacity with us from
Detroit is Jaime butters Bloomberg News
transportation team leader Jaime so how
big an announcement is this rail he's
going to put a lot of cameras in these
cars as I understand it yeah that's
right going from one camera per car just
facing out to now eight of them
including three facing forward and 360
degree view he says basically every car
is going to have a super computer on
board able to make whatever it is 40
trillion decisions per second and it's
just a pretty pretty amazing thing and
of course the shares are down a little
today because he's adding all this cost
all this hardware and software
development expense into these cars that
you can't use this stuff right you can't
you're not allowed most of us are not
allowed to drive to let our car do the
driving for us and most of America or
most of the world
so Jaime how does he pay for that I mean
the issue equity gives you no debt
market does he raise prices on the cars
that he's trying to cut prices on well
you know we'll see one thing that might
happen is that a lot of you know there
was this a big push for model 3 when he
first introduced it kind of promising
this model 3 part 2 which is now you
know the at least hardware to do full
autonomy if and when it becomes legal
maybe they get another rush of orders
for the model 3 that would help finance
the development of the rest of it but
we'll see he always this when he said
that they weren't going to need that
they might not need more capital this
quarter presumably he already knew that
he was undertaking this and adding these
expenses so again possibly a positive
sign so is it Jimmy he's his biggest
problem model 3 actually getting more
orders I thought he got a lot of orders
the question is can he make all those
cars and now isn't he making a little
bit harder to make them is making it
harder to make them more and it's
putting more strain on the supply chain
but they've had a lot of success working
with Nvidia that's the the chip maker
behind us and one of the things they're
trying to prove right he's trying to
retake leadership in this space right so
you know GM has already come out with
the cheaper electric car but they're not
going to sell it the volumes that he's
aiming to sell it if he can produce that
well they are producing better than they
were they beat targets for the third
quarter so they some things could be
going right but they what they're trying
to do is develop the track record the
digital track record to say these are
the lives that could be saved if you
would let the cars do the driving
because 80 or 90 percent of the 35 to 40
thousand Americans killed on roads every
year are their own fault you know if we
were better robots and less animals that
fall asleep or drink alcohol and make
bad decisions or get distracted by our
texting you know or war seatbelts even
you know we would avoid a lot of these
deaths but we don't and so that's that's
what they're trying to offer but Jimmy
here's what confuses me about Tesla is
it a car company or is it a tech company
does he unless need to decide well we'll
see you know it had been that Tesla was
really the pure play for electric cars
if you believe cars were going electric
other companies were doing it but Tesla
was the only one that was only doing
electric now you know they're at if they
can add solar city it becomes a little
Messier it's more of a pure play on
clean energy and lifestyle of the future
which is maybe less of a pure play more
of just a a play but you're buying into
Elon Musk and his vision which is solar
power you know home generation power
your car without you know without
polluting the environment